In order to help the garbage collector do its job,
you want to be sure you're not holding on to objects
that you no longer need. The easiest way to do
this is to use an appropriate scope for your variables. Instead
of using a global variable, that you then have to
dynamically allocate and de-allocate, just use a function scope local variable.
When it goes out of scope the garbage collector can take
care of it. Also, be sure to unbind any event listeners
before the dumb objects they're bound to are to be removed.
And finally, if you're using a local data cache be sure to
clean the cache through using aging mechanism to avoid any large
chunks of data being stored that you don't really need any more.